well I think what sparked it for me was
when they burnt the guy in the cage it's
sick of me and we all kind of got
together and decided they were on our
our internet so we were gonna try and
get him kicked off and what makes you
think that these things you're finding
are real and they're not either just
people mucking around or even something
that the security services have put
there to try and attract would be
daddy's we check and double-check and
triple-check and that's why they're
that's why we work well as a group
because if one of us finds something
three or four of the others will take it
and check it and double check and triple
check it to make sure that it's not you
know something unofficial or or
something that's a false flag what I'm
not working I'm usually involved with
something on this guns for the other
guys too if we're not actually at work
we are working on something Ferguson or
about go sack or with go sec and not the
only think we get is sleeping d fear for
their safety or your safety if anyone
found out what you were doing if if they
find out who I was I would be concerned
but I have and how politically correct
this is but I have a pretty good Arsenal
to protect myself so you're just and you
know dozen hackers no doubt you're very
skilled and you're working a lot of
hours on this but do you think you
deserve all the credit that you're being
given because you can't actually achieve
that much can you we are absolutely
disrupting the lines of communication
between these guys because when we do
take out one of the websites work take
out the twitter account a lot of times
we get we get reprisal from week
it our website gets hit a lot and has
counter-attack to this and we get will
get a DM they'll make another account
will get a DM about what it what what
dogs we are you know and and so we are
disrupting but i think the word the war
needs to be fought on the ground as much
as what we are doing and we're trying to
do our part to keep that from happening
but but i do believe that this faction
needs eliminated as quickly as possible
because it just seems to be growing and
growing and it's not good for the entire
world what about all the stuff you've
been doing with posting up viagra
adverts and stuff like that i mean is
that just a bit of fun or is that is
there a serious thing behind that we
just we wanted to make our statement you
know that they're there goofballs and
we're going to keep coming after you and
and when we're not this is serious
business to us but we're not gonna we're
not gonna lose our sense of humor as
we're going after them either I think
you can read any of our timelines and
you can see that we keep a sense of
humor to keep ourselves sane because a
lot of a lot of what we see in a low
yeah you can see this stuff and and now
so we try to keep our sense of humor and
that was just a way of saying huh you
know gotcha guys here you know